bonjour madame et merci d'être heures en
direct avec nous sur ard france à l'ap à
partir d'aujourd'hui donc les
adolescents de plus de 12 ans doivent
montrer patte blanche pour profiter de
nombreux lieux cela comprend les centres
sportifs en intérieur mais également en
extérieur sauf en milieu scolaire tout
d'abord quelles conséquences pour les
clubs
un bien l'ensemble de ces mesures que
nous avons depuis un certain temps
commence à porter préjudice au club
c'est très compliqué pour des bénévoles
de pouvoir appliquer toutes les mesures
dont cette dernière puisqu'on sait très
bien que ces jeunes qui n'ont pas besoin
de passer ni terre pour pratiquer du
sport à l'école vont être obligés d'en
avoir un pour aller en club donc c'est
très très compliqué en terme de gestion
pour les clubs justement les clubs
doivent organiser eux-mêmes les
contrôles de leurs jeunes adhérents ont
ils suffisamment les moyens de mettre ça
en place
b vous soulever un problème qui est
capital effectivement les clubs n'ont
pas forcément les moyens les très gros
clubs peuvent encore avoir les moyens de
le faire mais les petits clubs qui ont
déjà du mal à avoir un salarié vont
devoir à faire appel à leurs bénévoles
il faut savoir que les bénévoles ce sont
des gens qui ont aussi une activité
professionnelle et familiale donc ça va
être très très compliqué on nous ne
savons absolument pas comment cela va se
passer et là la grande inquiétude la
grande inquiétude c'est qu'en fait on
est en train de dire qu'il faut
absolument que nos jeunes adolescents
fassent du sport pour maintenir leur et
amanda mentale pardon et leur santé
physique et actuellement on est en train
de partir complètement en sens inverse
parce qu'il ne sonne va pas du tout
ainsi téléphone
alors activités
sportive possible justement à l'école
mais pas en club pour certains qui n'ont
pas donc de passani terre
deux poids deux mesures cette décision
selon vous so lu ment absolument
absolument là on est en train une fois
de plus et je trouve que c'est dommage
mais on est en train de favoriser une
fraction de la population qui a des pots
kirwa possibilité d'accéder à la
pratique sportive et on va voir un grand
nombre d'oublier et des jeunes qui
justement aurait besoin de pratiquer une
activité
alors on sait que le pass annie terre et
est instaurée d'une certaine manière
pour inciter les personnes à se faire
vacciner là en l'occurrence les jeunes
les mineurs de 12 à 17 ans sont
éligibles à la vaccination depuis le
mois de juin seulement
il y en a certains qui n'ont pas le
temps de se faire vacciner même s'ils le
souhaitent d'une certaine manière est ce
qu'on peut juger cette mesure
discriminatoire
tout à fait moi je et ainsi que massage
par l'eau au
sommet club 1 et puis pour les clubs de
ses terrasses ion compactes avec
d'autres fédérations effectivement moi
j'estime que c'est discriminatoire cette
mesure est discriminatoire
c'est sûr qu'il faut qu on arrive quand
même à endiguer cette pandémie mais là
je pense que franchement il ya une
discrimination
pourquoi on peut faire du sport à
l'école et qu'on puisse pas en faire en
club sympa sanitaire est ce que vous
avez vu constaté une baisse d'adhérents
depuis la rentrée cette année
oui alors déjà par rapport à la reprise
comme on est on s'attendait à ce qu'il y
ait un déficit de reprise de licence
mais là on ne peut absolument pas se
prononcer je pense avant 5 octobre
novembre parce que effectivement vous
avez des jeunes bien qu'ils n'iront pas
en plaques vous avez des parents qui
sont en attente donc je pense que ça va
être encore une baisse de licences
importantes alors qu'on nous demande
d'avoir
grand nombre de pratiquants en plus en
vue de nos prochains jeux olympiques qui
seront organisées en france dernière
question concernant cette fois-ci les
adultes qui travaillent dans ces clubs
sportifs est ce que là aussi vous avez
des problèmes est ce que des personnes
sont restées sans talent vaccination
comment ça se passe
bien sûr comme partout et la
problématique on en rajoute encore une
puisque en fait il me semble qu'il ya un
grand vide juridique et que les les
éducateurs qui ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner ou qu'ils ne veulent pas faire
deux pas sanitaire donc ne peuvent plus
pratiquer l'activité ça veut dire que
des clubs qui ont déjà du mal à avoir un
éducateur vont se retrouver à refuser
les personnes qui se présenteront à la
porte du club parce qu'ils n'auront pas
de personnel bon ça n'a pas la grande
majorité mais ça existe merci beaucoup
en tout cas à brigitte indoor d'avoir
répondu à nos questions genre la cia
vous êtes présidente de la fédération
nationale du sport en milieu rural